also i don't know why i started getting
recommended videos about like breathing
from your mouth and i don't know why i
was getting recommended this stuff
but i watched it i watched my other
mouth
i watched it i watched it and it was
like it was it was one of those videos
where it's like
this is this would if i wasn't dumb as
[ __ ] this would be so convincing like
yeah it felt so manipulative these
videos that they were like look
there's twins one of them was allergic
to hamsters and they had a hamster in
their room
and thus he couldn't breathe through his
nose and look what happened to his
chin it's all gross they just showed
like a [ __ ]
picture of leafy or something like that
oh why are you gonna do them like that
that's bullying bro one of them is leafy
and the other guys like
well it was like it was like yeah it was
like one had like a clearly defined chin
this is like a [ __ ] one had like a
clearly defined chin and one had like
the i don't even know what you call it
it's like that not really a chit it's
kind of like it leads into it yeah
yeah and that's generally believed to be
unattractive amongst
sigma members
i love that as well um that's why your
chin is like
getting swallowed into your neck kinda
yeah and
it's one of those things where you're
like huh everyone i did meet
who i feel like had that kind of face
did breathe through their mouth i think
and then it's one of those things where
it kind of it builds on your
your just like ignorance of it and your
anecdotal evidence of it right but then
i
you know i saw more videos about it and
i was like you know the more i feel like
it the more the more
this is like feels like some kind of
sigma male [ __ ] this you know what i
mean i felt like i was getting fed but i
don't know how accurate it is because
then i start watching videos about
apparently doctors who specialize in uh
what they'll do is that
they'll uh [ __ ] what they do they'll do
something so that when you sleep or when
you normally do it that you breathe
through your mouth and they look it's
fixed
his chin is [ __ ] normal well they're
just like here's some tape i don't know
put her on your mouth
i didn't to learn more about it or check
how
real it was but now it's in your head no
you're just like but what if i do
breathe
but also i generally want to breathe
through my nose anyway because it's just
the whole of
you know when you breathe through your
mouth your it isn't being filtered and
[ __ ] and
yeah i i'd like to live as long as i can
so i can be as stubborn as i can for as
long as i can
i mean like maybe i can become a
japanese politician and make life
healthy
full circle i mean i feel like you do
breathe through your nose most of the
time
um you can only tell who the mouth
breathers are because
can you let me finish myself okay
you can only tell who the mouth is are
when you're like you're you're in a
hotel room and there's always
the one snorer who is just like you you
know you know sometimes when you're like
yeah sometimes when you're really quiet
when when you're really tired but
sometimes you you are with a group of
mates and you know who the [ __ ]
snorer is right yeah and it's like a
[ __ ] time limit
of just like all right i've got
literally half an hour to fall asleep or
i'm not sleeping tonight and
it's and it's not just the snorers right
because there are the snorers that do it
through their nose
and then there are the snores that do it
through them oh you can tell when people
snore through their mouths yeah yeah
it's just no it's so weird because like
i grew up breathing
through my mouth so i was a mouth
breather when i was sleeping
when i was like so funny but that's
because i had like horrible hay fever so
like my nose was
constantly blocked all the time
a lot of people not me it's a pretty
good descriptive insult because i feel
like you know as much as uh
as much as i i wouldn't use it you get a
very good picture of what they're trying
to paint when someone calls you a mouth
breather
[Laughter]
[Music]
for a little bit i definitely became
paranoid that i was breathing through my
mouth am i becoming a malaria
[Music]
because i feel like i have a
semi-defined chain i guess i don't know
yeah
semi-defined i don't know i i'm not even
going to
and i was like yeah i did breathe
through my nose as a kid but then again
again it's i feel like it all
goes on anecdotal evidence you know
everything again i don't know how
accurate it is it seemed
it felt like pseudoscience when i was
watching this [ __ ] pretty much pretty
much
it was enough to make me care even
though i know i shouldn't now you've
made like a lot of people
watching this yeah everyone watching
this can be like oh [ __ ] do you want to
read my mouth
just doing this just like do i have a
chin am i good
am i good isn't it sad that we give a
[ __ ] about chins